[Musique]
me
bonjour bonjour à tous et bienvenue nous
vous proposons aujourd'hui l'audition de
la ministre des sports sur un thème que
le sénat scrute avec grande attention la
radicalisation islamiste
il s'agit en effet de la troisième
commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur le
sujet depuis 2015 il sera question
aujourd'hui notamment de la
radicalisation dans le milieu du sport
amateur et professionnel on regarde on
en reparle juste après pire je ne sais
pas si vous aviez reçu le questionnaire
je suis certaine que nous avons adressé
un questionnaire où nous allions
demander plusieurs précisions est ce que
vous êtes en mesure de de nouvelles
données et de répondre au questionnaire
souhaitez-vous l'emphase sur la mesure
puisque l'on demandait certaines données
chiffrées notamment sur la montée du
prosélytisme religieux ou des incidents
à caractère religieux que vous avez vu
détectée qui 15 ans dans le secteur du
sport nous vous demandez pourquoi
d'après vous aujourd'hui encore nous
avons entendu il nous avons en audition
des faits relatés assez stupéfiant
pourquoi le sport est liée autant de
temps à se rendre compte de cette
problématique de radicalisation et a
permis à effectivement à cette
radicalisation de rentrer dans certains
clubs sportifs
sans vouloir les montrer du doigt et
nous savons que le foot la boxe d'autres
d'autres sports effectivement nous
abriter du prosélytisme et que
aujourd'hui pour certaines pour certains
quartiers c'est un vraie problématique
et enfin par rapport à ces actes
prosélytisme quelles sont les sanctions
puisque l'on a vu qu'il était assez
difficile pour le ministère des sports
d'agir directement il fallait le faire
si en face d'associations aussi de
fédérations qui ont une certaine
autonomie donc quelle est votre marge de
manoeuvre en tant que ministre des
sports voilà ça c'est une première heure
bak de question que je souhaitais vous
posez je suppose que madame le
rapporteur on aura beaucoup aussi et
vous en mesure de pouvoir nous donner
des précisions par rapport à notre
questionnaire maman merci
alors bien sûr nous avons préparé un
certain nombre de données que nous
mettons à votre disposition nous allons
vous envoyer les données chiffrées
maintenant si vous voulez des réponses
j'allais dire plus plus générale nous
pouvons échanger sur ces sujets bien
évidemment je crois que le phénomène de
radicalisation dans la société et aussi
est un phénomène dont la nôtre société a
pris conscience il n'y a pas si
longtemps que cela
finalement donc dire que le sport n'en a
pas pris conscience finalement cessé il
faut il faut qu'on réalise que le sport
n'est que le miroir de la société
même au moment où on parle de violence
sexuelle dans le sport évidemment c'est
pas dans le sport que ça se passe
précisément c'est comme la
radicalisation c'est pas dans le sport
que ça se passe précisément lorsqu'on on
trouve des personne déviante et qui ont
aujourd'hui qui sont passés de la
radicalisation au terrorisme et qu'on
les a arrêtés et qu'on a regardé leur
parcours de vie
inévitablement comme beaucoup de
personnes en france
elles sont passées par un club sportif
donc de la faire un raccourci à dire que
c'est dans le sport qu'elle se sont
radicalisés voilà c'est pas la même
chose de dire la personne quand on
regarde son parcours de vie est passée
par un club sportif et là il y avait
possibilité pour elles peut-être de
rencontrer d'autres personnes et de
faire de les convaincre à sa cause
ou éventuellement dans un sport sportif
dans un club sportif d'aller vers des
pratiques qui servent sa cause
parce que c'était un club de combat où
c'était un club où il a appris à tirer
ou effectivement mais aujourd'hui
clairement nous n'avons pas de données
précises chiffrées scientifique époux
éprouvée pour dire qu'il ya un réel lien
entre le la pratique sportive dans une
association ou en dehors d'une
association et la radicalisation c'est
pour cela que ce que nous poussons
fortement c'est aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'obtenir ces études est de
faire de vraies études sérieuses
universitaire sur ce sujet d'autant plus
que le phénomène
on le voit dans l'est dans les
différents discours qu'on entend est
difficilement cernable en fait entre je
me permettrai pas ce que vous dans votre
question il y avait le mot prosélytisme
religieux religieux aujourd'hui si on
veut rentrer dans la définition de ces
termes
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le
prosélytisme
aujourd'hui dans le droit fait partie de
la liberté de conscience et de religion
l'expression religieuse en soi n'est pas
incompatible avec la pratique d'un sport
dans un cadre associatif de droit privé
et y compris dans des équipements
sportifs public ce qu'on peut nous
ministère des sports détecter si tenté
que nous en avons l'occasion c'est
est-ce que ce prosélytisme entrave
l'ordre public le bon fonctionnement du
club
est-ce qu'ils entravent les règles
d'hygiène et de sécurité
est ce que il
c'est un comportement abusif et excessif
si on regarde les populations qui sont
accueillis dans les clubs étant donné
que dans certains clubs il s'agit de
l'accueil de mineurs avec une relation
hiérarchique entre un entraîneur ou un
adultes et plusieurs enfants
donc effectivement à partir du moment où
déjà on a on a du mal à qualifier
juridiquement ces notions et déjà le
juge lui-même a du mal à les qualifier
j'allais dire quelqu'un qui est mandatée
par le ministère des sports et doit
aller contrôler une association sportive
avec une feuille de route qui a priori
n'est pas celle ci puisque quand
quelqu'un de mon ministère va contrôler
une association sportive
il va y mener un contrôle en conformité
des diplômes de l'éducateur des règles
d'exercice de cet éducateur dans cette
dans cette association de la bonne
conformité de l'équipement en lien avec
la pratique qui est proposé et le
ministère des sports ce n'est pas lui
qui a les compétences aujourd'hui de
détecter une personne radicalise et
c'est bien pourquoi c'est bien pour cela
que depuis la circulaire de 2018
signée entre le ministère des sports le
ministère de l'intérieur le choix qui a
été fait c'est de cibler certaines
associations qui ont été elles détectée
par le ministère de l'intérieur de mener
à bien ces contrôles de manière ciblée
et puis derrière chacun dans notre
périmètre d'apporter l'éclairage les uns
aux autres de ce qui peut relever d'un
incident j'allais dire dans l'incident
comme vous dites dans votre question qui
pour être relative à la laïcité mais
encore faut-il s'entendre sur ce qu'est
la laïcité puisque voilà chacun peut en
avoir aussi sa propre définition alors
que celle ci elle est clairement inscrit
dans la loi le défait de radicalisation
de prosélytisme de séparatisme sachant
qu'un contrôle effet à un moment donné
que les personnes
sont informés qu'il va y avoir un
contrôle est évidemment si il y à de
telles pratiques
ça va pas se passer au moment où les
personnes vont venir contrôler donc nous
avons choisi au ministère des sports
plutôt d'axer notre action sur le fait
de sensibiliser et de former les
intervenants en milieu associatif à être
en capacité de repérer d'observer de
repérer les signes faible les signaux
faibles de pouvoir les reporter et les
ailes est signalé à l'administration
pour que du ministère des sports cela
puisse arriver au ministère de
l'intérieur et qu'on puisse croiser en
fait les données mais aujourd'hui le
ministère des sports n'est pas en
capacité lui même d'avoir accès à avoir
accès aux données auxquelles que le
ministère de l'intérieur gère et qui
d'ailleurs son secret défense
donc quand le ministère de l'intérieur
nous invite à aller contrôler avec eux
dans certaines associations pour que
nous puissions entre guillemets faire la
traduction de ce qu'est une association
sportive pour les personnes du ministère
de l'intérieur
nous le faisons mais nos contrôles à
nous ne cible pas cette thématique là
qui aujourd'hui nous l'avons fait au
moment où il ya eu 1 1
une inspection générale qui a été avait
été commandité par monsieur k nerfs et
qui avait proposé de faire dans chaque
département cinq contrôles de aps sur
cette thématique là sur l'ensemble des
contrôles
il y a eu cinq fermetures
d'établissements et sur les 5,3 été
motivée par d'autres motifs que des
motifs de radicalisation donc
aujourd'hui voilà ce motif n'est pas
[Musique]
celui pour lequel on va contrôler les
associations sportives très bien je vous
remercie je pense qu'à parole à un autre
rapporteur jacqueline eustache brinio
merci jacques ni merci donc j'ai bien
entendu tout ce que vous avez exposé
madame émises c'est sûr évidemment
l'intérêt du sport dans le cas de la
construction d'un jeune d'un adulte
il ya deux piliers sur lesquels nous
réfléchissons beaucoup dans le cadre de
cette commission c'est l'éducation et le
sport et nous sommes quand même
convaincu que si aujourd'hui vous êtes
là madame le ministre sait que l'iliade
il ya quelques soucis dans les
territoires qui font qu'on peut pas être
dans le déni d'un certain nombre de
difficultés dans le monde sportif
aujourd'hui je crois que dans le foot
c'est une réalité nous avons auditionné
les gens du le monde du foot et ils sont
bien conscients qu'elle vivait mais y en
a d'autres il y en a d'autres
je pense que c'est important que nous
ayons la même analyse et la même vision
des choses pour protéger cet
environnement sportif qui est une vraie
chance pour tous les enfants de ce pays
et tous les adultes qui pratiquent le
sport on en est bien convaincu alors
j'ai une petite différence avec vous
quand vous dites que la laïcité chacun
peut avoir sa propre définition non la
laïcité à mon sens y en a qu'une
elle n'a pas de qualificatifs et puis
voilà les notions de laïcité ouverte de
l'essai non si nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur déjà ce qu'est la laïcité
c'est sûr que ça va être difficile
d'écrire des choses
définitivement non pour moi il n'ya pas
chacun n'a pas sa propre démission de la
laïcité parce qu'elle remet en cause le
socle de cette république si chacun y
met sa petite dose d'interprétation ça
c'est mon point de vue personnel
moi j'avais quelques questions à vous
poser en particulier vous avez parlé
dans vos propos dans vos explications
vous avez évoqué des travaux en cours
sur le code de déontologie des
éducateurs sportifs
vous avez parlé de ce sujet qui
intégrait les valeurs de la république
donc je vais savoir si on avait une date
sur l'aboutissement de ces travaux je
veux savoir si dans cette analyse et ses
travaux vous avez rencontré des freins
pour pouvoir analyser objectivement la
situation
est-ce que vous allez définir un code
déontologie et est-ce que ça suffira
parce que je suis pas sûr que ça suffise
est-ce qu'il faut peut-être des outils
plus contraignant pour pouvoir et récent
deux choses et puis vous avez parlé
aussi dans les quartiers en particulier
les plus en difficulté les quartiers
petites de la ville
moi je vis dans une ville où il ya un
quartier politique de la ville monk et
peut-être pas le plus en difficulté vous
avez parlé d'association socio sportives
acquise à qui allait être donc mis en
place est ce que ces associations vont
être labellisées et comment vont être
donnés la belle et quels sont les
critères du label s'il y en a un
donc ça c'est important vous avez aussi
parlé de quelque chose d'important mais
j'ai pas bien compris vers quoi on
allait sur la mixité des pratiques
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous la mixité
des pratiques j'ai pas bien aime bien
compris mais peut-être que vous allez
pouvoir nous nous nous le définir
il ya quelque chose que j'ai pas compris
dans votre expression en disant que dans
le sport l'expression religieuse pouvait
éventuellement s'avérer m'ont pas un
vrai combat dans le cas du sport moi
j'ai pas bien compris cette phrase
et puis je voudrais évoquer avec vous
quelque chose qui me paraît extrêmement
important parce que vous avez abordé les
jeux olympiques dans vos propos est ce
qu'il ne serait pas intéressant
aujourd'hui d'introduire dans les
règlements des fédérations l'article 50
qui aujourd'hui réglerait un bon nombre
de problèmes puisque l'article 50 de la
charte olympique je rappelle elle prône
la neutralité politique et religieuse
donc pourquoi les fédérations
n'aurait-elle pas un article qui
pourrait aussi écrire ça définitivement
qui imposerait
cette neutralité d'ailleurs j'espère que
la france est accueillant les jeux
olympiques en 2024 on l'appliquera cet
article 5 ans à tous les pays sans
exception de manière à ce que la france
soit un peu l'honneur du monde sur la
neutralité religieuse et politique en
matière sportive c'est le moment où
jamais de montrer que nous serons des
fervents défenseurs de cet article 50 ça
c'est une petite parenthèse mais en tout
cas voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons une vraie difficulté dans le monde
sportif pendant tout le monde sportif
mais dans certains pans du champ sportif
de cette radicalisation de cette volonté
via le sport de mettre la main sur les
jeunes dans certains quartiers c'est une
réalité
c'est une réalité et je pense que si
nous menons pas le combat tous ensemble
de front ça va être un peu compliqué
donc voila moi je voudrais avoir des
réponses à ses questions sur la
déontologie des éducateurs est ce que on
peut pas aussi impliqué ou en tout cas
écrire au défi niro faire signer une
charte de la laïcité à tout les clubs et
associations qui bénéficierait d'argent
public parce que c'est aussi voilà on a
des droits mais on a aussi des devoirs
je pense qu'il faut dans le monde
sportif à voir des gestes forts pour
pouvoir préserver ce monde qui est un
outil extraordinaire de développement
individuel mais qui doit faire
abstraction de toute influence
religieuse quelle qu'elle soit
alors le la définition de la laïcité
n'est pas si simple que ça nous l'avons
vu dans le champ du sport en écoutant
les remontées de nos associations de nos
éducateurs de nos établissements et
c'est pour cela qu'on a décidé cette
année d'éditer et de transmettre à tout
le monde la laïcité le fait religieux
dans le champ du sport l'idée n'étant
pas de dire de définir la laïcité telle
que je sens que vous l'entendez à savoir
l'interdiction de tout signe religieux
dans la pratique sportive ce qui revient
à dire la neutralité et non pas la
laïcité mais bien au contraire expliqué
à nos associations à nos éducateurs que
le moment sportif étant un moment de
loisir c'est à dire un moment qui n'est
pas obligatoire dans la vie de nos
concitoyens et encore moins de celle de
leurs enfants
si on en arrivait a effectivement prôner
la neutralité dans le dans ce moment de
loisir il serait est assez simple pour
ses parents et ses enfants de claquer la
porte de cette association d'aller en
ouvrir une autre et de finalement
proposé à leurs enfants du sport pour
leur fille du sport pour leurs garçons
de manière séparée du sport encadré
d'une certaine manière idéologique pour
les filles d'une autre manière
idéologique pour les garçons et là on
sait la ignorait complètement de des
valeurs de la république en tout cas de
celle que je défends qui sont celles
donc vous avez évoqué qui sont celles de
la mixité
d'abord c'est à dire les filles et les
garçons qui pratiquent au même endroit
et on sait que sans rentrer même dans le
débat de la religion déjà dans le monde
sportif
arriver à faire en sorte que les femmes
et les jeunes filles aient plus accès au
sport c'est déjà un combat en soit ça
faire faire un
faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
femmes dans les instances dirigeantes
des clubs des associations des
fédérations des grandes institutions
c'est déjà un combat en soi sans rentrer
dans une dans une séparation des hommes
allaient et des femmes dues à la
religion dont déjà le fait sportif
engendre cette non mixité de fait et le
fait de dire finalement dans le sport
dans ce moment de loisir dans ce moment
de liberté dans ce moment de société
nous allons faire pareil qu'à l'école je
pense que ça va être plus exclusifs
qu'un clusif moi le sport que je défends
c'est un sport inclusif où tout le monde
ya sa place où tout le monde arrive
comme il est et c'est un sport qui va
permettre de construire l'individu et
qui va lui permettre de découvrir ce
qu'est l'autre de s'exprimer sur ce
qu'il est ou sur ce que ses parents sont
ou sur ce que sa culture son origine lui
lui a amené dans sa construction
d'enfants et le sport peut avoir cette
vocation éducative
parce que de mon point de vue justement
le sport peut amener vers la citoyenneté
parce que c'est de la citoyenneté
incarné à partir du moment où tout le
monde va se présenter comme à l'école
sans aucun signe distinctif et tout le
monde va être obligé de faire pareil
comme c'est un moment facultatif et bien
les parents vont choisir de retirer
l'enfant de cette association où
finalement c'est le seul endroit où ils
peuvent venir comme il est et où il peut
aller vers un autre donc vers une autre
chose qui pour moi est un idéal
républicain et à ce moment là c'est là
qu'on va aller vers du séparatisme et
vers des dérives communautaires donc
tout l'enjeu de ces actes de ces acteurs
socio sportives dont vous avez parlé et
que nous voulons promouvoir dans les
quartiers peut-être les plus compliqués
par rapport à ceux à se faire religieux
eh bien ils ont cette vocation et c'est
pas nous qui l'écrivons ils existent
déjà et sont là depuis bien longtemps
mais le ministère des sports ne les
avait jamais reconnue et ne les avez
jamais financé l'année dernière nous
avons débloqué 2 millions d'euros à
l'agencé nationale des sports pour
lancer un appel à projet ne serait ce
que pour les cartographier en france
avoir une vision et un contact avec elle
au final nous avons eu 800 associations
qui ont répondu nous avons augmenté
notre fonds d'un million supplémentaire
cette année il va encore augmenter de
manière à pouvoir vraiment créer un lien
avec ces associations à pouvoir voir où
elles sont dans les territoires à
appuyer leur présence est proposée
effectivement un label citoyen
républicain à celle qui s'engageront à
nos côtés grâce à la signature d'une
convention spécifique puisque la plupart
d'entre elles ne sont pas fédéral elles
font partie d'un réseau associatif pas
forcément toujours fédéral nous essayons
aujourd'hui de créer des ponts entre ce
réseau associatif et les fédérations
pour qu'elles puissent rentrer dans un
cadre que nous maîtrisons mieux et plus
parce qu'avec les fédérations nous avons
plus de levier d'action nous avons le
contrat de délégation que je désire
renforcer nous avons les projets
sportifs fédéraux sur lesquels ces
associations peuvent s'engager pour
l'inclusion l'insertion des publics les
plus fragiles dans les quartiers et qui
ont besoin justement du soutien et de
l'accompagnement de nos éducateurs et
puis travailler de l'autre côté sur la
formation de ses éducateurs grâce à ces
modules de formation qui j'ai souhaité
qu'il ne soit pas thématisée et que ce
module éthique et intégrité lorsqu'il
intègre lorsqu'il intègre la formation
initiale ou la formation continue des
éducateurs qu'ils soient justement dans
un dans une cohérence d'ensemble sur
toutes les dérives que peut connaître le
sport
eh bien nous voulons aller dans le sens
de ce à quoi je crois c'est à dire que
les valeurs du sport ne sont pas
intrinsèque au sport les valeurs du
sport elle sont portés par des
éducateurs qui sont au contact des
enfants et c'est sur ces encadrants là
sur leur valeur à eux qu'il faut qu'on
travaille qu'il faut qu'on initie ce
travail parce qu'aujourd'hui dans les
modules de formation ces modules
existent mais ils sont optionnelles ils
ne sont pas évalués et aujourd'hui on
veut enrichir le contenu on veut les
rendre obligatoires
on veut que dans les formations et un
temps spécifique qui leur est accordé
et puis derrière qu'ils soient évalués
au moment de la formation initiale mais
ça ne suffit pas il ya beaucoup
d'éducateurs aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont
pas passés par ce type de formation donc
il faut que ce soit aussi de la
formation continue et il faut qu'on
croise les regards
parce qu'encore une fois c'est pas parce
qu'un éducateur a suivi ces modules de
formation qui ne va pas en dévier une
fois qu'il va être en activité
de toute façon il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que d'avoir des regards croisés
entre les personnes qui accueillent des
associations dans les équipements
sportifs donc les personnels municipaux
qui sont là ouvrir le gymnase chaque
jour qui sont en capacité de détecter ce
qu'il se passe dans les vestiaires de
détecter et d'alerté derrière sur des
comportements qui effectivement pourrait
toucher à la à la déviance de
l'association sportive de son objet
initial parce qu'encore une fois je le
redis le prosélytisme n'est pas interdit
en france
il ne l'est pas il n'est pas interdit
même au sein d'une association
aujourd'hui c'est le fait qu'une
association sportive n'est pas le droit
d'utiliser un équipement pour autre
chose que pour la pratique sportive et
qu'elle n'est pas le droit de de
rassembler des enfants pour un autre
objet que la pratique sportive parce que
ça fait partie
voilà si son objet c'est la pratique
sportive il n'a pas le droit de les
rassembler pour faire la prière ensemble
ou pour faire autre chose pour les faire
prier donc c'est à ça qu'on veille et
c'est à ça qu'on veillera pas autre
chose
ouais je voulais revenir ce mot provost
parce que les propos qui me perturbe
on est tous d'accord et je pense qu'on
se bat pour ça pour dire que le sport
comme l'école sont des vecteurs
d'intégration républicaine et porter
valeurs républicaines que nous défendons
et si cette commission existe que nous
pensons que certains socle de notre
république sont en danger aujourd'hui il
reprendre vos propos m'interroge pour
partie d'un principe que dans le sport
qui est un loisir qui pas obligatoire
les gens viennent s'ils en ont envie
on peut pas aborder les choses de la
même manière qu'à l'école qui est que
l'école parce que l'école est
obligatoire
ça veut dire que en gros ça peut-être
j'exagère mais vous êtes là vous me
reprendre et on baisse un peu les bras
dans le monde sportif et on laisse faire
les choses parce que c'est un caractère
non obligatoire pour moi c'est céder aux
pressions communautaristes quand on dit
ça parce que ça veut dire qu'on laisse
faire des choses sous prétexte que si on
était un peu plus exigeants des gens qui
a créé les portes moi je pense que celle
inverse ce qu'il faut faire c'est en
étant exigeant qu'on les garde avec nous
et qui ne s'éloigne pas mais ça c'est un
point de vue très personnel
donc du coup je suis un peu inquiète et
je me dis du coup avec vos propos pour
vous pour vous à la ministre
quelle est la place de l'expression
religieuse dans le sport parce que c'est
presque ça que vous avez dit on peut
laisser faire parce que c'est pas
obligatoire on n'a pas les mêmes
objectifs les mêmes contraintes qu'à
l'école donc quelle est pour vous la
place de l'expression religieuse dans le
sport parce que c'est un peu de ça dont
vous avez parlé en disant qu'il fallait
pas rejeter les gens me sens on est tous
d'accord qu'il faut pas rejeter mais en
même temps aujourd'hui la république
elle doit lutter donc je ne sais pas
comment on peut lutter quand on laisse
l'expression religieuse dans le sport
alors j'ai peut-être pas compris ce que
vous avez dit mais en tout cas vos
propos me font penser qu'il ya quelque
chose de ça alors l'expression
religieuse dans le sport elle n'a pas sa
place
on ne vient pas dans un club sportif
d'accord mais ça mais ça va jusqu'où ça
va jusqu'où c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on
est ce qu'on est très classe sur un peu
venir dans un club sportif comme on est
voilà il ya des règles si ça revienne à
la sécurité et à l'hygiène de la
pratique sportive que le port du voile
ne vous gêne pas car de la famille
sportive sa mère dans le règlement si je
lis que le règlement voile vous gêne
dans la pratique sportive par exemple
qui est une expression religieuse alors
le port
du voile n'est pas du prosélytisme mais
c'est un signe religieux on est d'accord
c'est un signe religieux on peut venir
avec sa croix autour du cou on peut
venir avec son voile ne paraît pas être
roi et le moral quand même là où on ne
peut pas le faire avec son voile sur sa
tête c'est lorsque le voile va
contrevenir aux règlements sportifs et
pas pour des raisons religieuses mais
simplement parce que pour des questions
de sécurité on va pas pouvoir pratiquer
du judo de la lutte correctement ou
parce qu'il ya un risque d'étranglement
si si ça ne gêne pas la pratique
sportive en tant que tels si c'est un
jeu de ballon
voilà on peut venir comme on est dans ce
moment de loisir comme on peut se
balader dans la rue dans la société
normal enfin à part à l'école la laïcité
c'est ça c'est on peut aujourd'hui le
respect de la laïcité dans le sport et
pour qu'on n'impose pas dans le junior
complètement aussi comme à l'école
pourquoi la question ne se pose pas ce
post elle pas pour qu'on ne la poserai
pas aussi de la même manière qu'on les
associe à l'école ce sont des entités de
droit privé une association de droit
privé ce ne sont pas des endroits où les
fonctionnaires exercent leur métier ce
sont des gens qui sont employés sur
contrats de droit privé ce sont des
bénévoles aujourd'hui qui interviennent
dans les associations et mise à part
dans des fédérations qui ont choisi
d'inclure dans leur règlement intérieur
ou le fait de la neutralité
mais au moment des compétitions
simplement au moment des compétitions
fédérales où elle préconise alors le la
réalité des faits n'est pas toujours
celle ci parce que même à la télé nous
voyons parfois des signes religieux sur
des compétitions nationales sur un
joueur qui rentre en en faisant sa croix
sur le terrain il va pas être exclu
directement va pas sifflé alors que
c'est dans le règlement fédéral que delà
de la fédération française de football
mais
aujourd'hui pour moi de mon point de vue
inclure cette neutralité dans le monde
du sport irait plutôt dans un sens
d'exclusion aujourd'hui des individus de
notre société que dans un sens
inclusif et le sport que je défends est
un sport inclusif qui permet d'accepter
les gens dans une pratique sportive qui
respecte les règles républicaines et que
c'est un moyen pour moi de travailler ce
sujet-là de l'intérieur mais
véritablement de le travailler et non
pas de s'en défaire en dix ans parce que
c'est vrai que finalement la neutralité
dans le sport ce serait très simple ce
serait beaucoup plus simple que de
travailler ce sujet là de faire
s'interroger les gens de faire de leur
faire se poser des questions sur cette
thématique est de trouver des réponses
qui vont plutôt dans l'acceptation de
l'individu est dans les mains des dans
l'émancipation de ces individus qui
viennent à la pratique sportive que de
dire de fait comme j'ai déjà entendu sur
les différentes sessions que nous
faisons sur les territoires autour de
cette thématique
ah bah moi je respecte je fais et
respecter la laïcité dans le sport la
preuve notre notre adhérentes la
dernière fois elle était venue sans
voile et la première fois qu'il est venu
son voile je lui ai dit tu rentres à la
maison et tu reviens plus voilà moi pour
moi ce n'est pas une solution
la jeune fille elle est effectivement
parti elle n'est plus revenue est ce que
pour autant on a réglé le problème
est ce que pour autant elle a enlevé son
voile est ce que pour autant si c'était
ça qu'on recherchait moi personnellement
c'est pas ce que je recherche
peut-être que la dame qui l'a viré de
son club de fait parce que c'était de
boxe de lutte de judo c'est ce qu'elle
peut être ce qu'elle recherchait mais
est-ce qu'on a résolu le problème je ne
pense pas je pense que l avait peut-être
un parcours plus intéressant à faire au
sein de cette association elle avait un
parcours plus intéressant au sein à
faire au sein de notre république et
c'est pas parce que elle portait un
voile que d'un seul coup toutes les
filles de l'association se serait mise à
porter un voile
s'ils tentaient que nous pensons que le
voile est un signe de prosélytisme
religieux et c'est ça que nous voulons
combattre entre le ressens tu as dit
madame la ministre tenu et
restait la parole à notre collègue jean
marie bockel qui est en train et
j'espère que nous arriverons à
l'entendre comme il faut et ensuite je
vous poserai moi même quelques questions
jean marie bockel alors je
j'en arrive peut-être quelques
difficultés pour se connecter jean marie
est ce que tu tu arrives à être
connectée est ce que tu nous entends
n'ont pour l'instant nous assaillent et
oui voilà maintenant moi je vous entends
est-ce que vous m'entendez je suis dans
le train c'est pas évident oui nous
tendons oui alors écoutez je vois la
joie et bien sûr je salue la ministre
que je connais bien puisque elle était
située à une blouse et quelle a été
votre fierté comme sportive
nous n'avons pas toujours été d'accord
politiquement mais j'ai évidemment
beaucoup d'estimé pour elle par contre
je partage les questionnements de la
rapportant à l'instant et les réponses
de la ministre et le rapporteur en fait
m'amène à dire là la chaussure je pense
que il faut être pragmatique il ne faut
pas empêcher des jeunes de faire à
parcours à la république ça je l'entends
mais tout dépend de là où on parle de
mon point de vue quand on est ministre
de la république surtout dans le
contexte français actuel il est
important d'être clair sur un certain
nombre de principes et accepter
certaines réalités sur le est une chose
la frontière entre l'axé
et
j'en arrive de temps en temps non plus
pour le moment alors nous allons voir si
la connexion se rétablit apparemment non
le temps que jean-marie puisse se
rétablir je ne sais pas si d'autres
collègues demande la parole dans la
salle pour rebondir sur les propos de
jean-marie c'est vrai que madame la
ministre
[Musique]
même si nous avons tous beaucoup de
respect pour la championne que vous avez
été c'est vrai que les propos de la
ministre que vous êtes me semble un peu
l'axé c'est à dire que effectivement ne
s'entend pas limites que ne doivent pas
dépasser les personnes qui viennent
effectivement dans ces clubs ou les
personnes qui forment dans ses clubs et
nous voyons au quotidien nous avons des
propos au quotidien et les faits qui
nous sont relatés au quotidien qui nous
disent que eh bien oui ça a commencé
quelques signaux et puis ensuite le
bureau a été renouvelé
le sport a été interdite
il ment quand on est un peu trop
laxistes qui les fait pour chercher un
effet contraire donc par rapport à ça
c'est vrai que nous sommes assez je
pense surpris par les propos que vous
tenez
même si nous comprenons la philosophie
de dire il ne faut pas interdire
l'entrée dans les clubs est né du coup
je pense que vous ne recherchez pas
d'outils législatifs ou es ce que vous
avez besoin d'outils législatifs
complémentaires pour vous aider à mener
cette reconquête comme vous l'avez dit
quand même de certains territoires qui
passe aussi par la reconquête des
associations dans certains de ses
territoires entre temps j'espère que
nous avons récupéré jean marie bockel je
ne sais pas moi je vais je vais je vais
vous poser en fait la question
finalement de la mesure parce que vous
me dites vous avez des choses qui vous
remontent des faits qui vous remonte
n'hésitez pas à nous en faire part
puisque quand je moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de
signalement qui nous remontent ni de la
part des collectivités ni de la part des
fédérations ni de la part des éducateurs
nous en avons un certain nombre et nous
menons des contrôles on a eu des
contrôles ciblés qui ont augmenté on a
les chiffres nous voulait donneront
aujourd'hui 171 171 contrôle ciblé à
partir de faits qui nous sont remontés
en collaboration avec le ministère de
l'intérieur
le résultat de ces contrôles ouais c'est
des fermetures administratives pour
quelques fermetures administratives mais
pas avec l'objet de radicalisation
expressément voilà visible et mis en
avant donc quand je vous dis qu'on a
besoin vraiment de données précises
d'études et de
d'études approfondies et pas juste de de
quelqu'un qui dit ça se passe beaucoup
dans le sport où ça arrive beaucoup dans
le sport qu'est ce que ça veut dire
beaucoup
aujourd'hui dans le fichier des
personnes radicaliser on considère qu'il
y à 1000 personnes qui auraient eu lieu
qui aurait eu un lien particulier avec
le chant du sport sur 30 millions de
pratiquants mille personnes voilà ça
fait pas beaucoup finalement maintenant
ça n'exclut pas toutes les actions que
nous faisons nous avons aujourd'hui
depuis 2016 mis en place des référents
radicalisation des référents éthique et
intégrité aussi bien dans nos directions
départementales régionales dans nos
établissements dans nos fédérations on
en compte aujourd'hui 210 à qui nous
faisons une sensibilisation et une
formation accrue sur ces thématiques
ils sont en mesure aujourd'hui est de
diffuser cette formation est cette
sensibilisation à tous les acteurs de
manière à nous permettre de nous faire
remonter des informations qui nous
amènerait bien évidemment à être en
capacité derrière de contrôler et de
rendre compte effectivement d'un certain
nombre de fermetures liées à cette
thématique
aujourd'hui je vous fait part de cette
fermeture
aujourd'hui sur le alors vous avez beau
dire ben vous chercher peut-être pas au
bon endroit parce que moi j'en ai
entendu parler ailleurs mais voilà
aujourd'hui avec les outils qu'on a et
la vigilance qu'on mène nous avons
trouvé ces sept cas quoi madame la
ministre ce n'est pas forcément des
fermetures qui nous intéresse mais c'est
plutôt les signalements qui ont pu être
faits et le travail que vous allez faire
ensuite il y a des signes avant coureurs
qui effectivement ne sont pas de nature
à demander une fermeture mais une
étroite surveillance
ou en tout cas un recadrage de la
structure supra pâques
aujourd'hui en tout cas la commission
n'est pas à la recherche de dire il faut
fermer
bien sûr quand c'est nécessaire mais
c'est tout ce travail de prévention de
la radicalisation nous entendons mai
mais effectivement on a l'impression que
tel que signes avant coureurs ne sont
pas problématiques et du cou
l'interrogation de mes collègues se fait
dans la graduation c'est à dire que pour
vous à quel moment et selon quoi
s'inquiéter
quels sont pour vous les les premiers
signes plus la graduation
effectivement on se dit là c'est pas
grave on verra il faut attendre que ça
soit un peu plus âgés pour ça soit grave
eh bien on sait que dans ce délai la se
propage certaines idées certaines
influences qui sont de nature à mettre
en danger et notamment des jeunes des
jeunes adultes des mineurs et à les
faire douter et peut-être basculé alors
qu'il ne l'aurais pas fait si ces signes
avaient été pris bien en allemand que ça
ne semble l'être aujourd'hui
là c'est plutôt des précisions de ce
type là que je voulais j'en profite pour
demander officiellement effectivement si
nous pouvons avoir des réponses
détaillées à notre questionnaire et
notamment là vous nous parliez de
contrôle suite à la demande de monsieur
canal si nous pouvons aussi avoir le
bilan de ces contrats bien sûr vous les
aurez si vous voulez je peux je peux
vous fournir le rapport doligé de
l'époque
maintenant évidemment moi je n'ai jamais
dit qu'il fallait
à partir du moment où il ya un signe et
j'imagine que si vous êtes au courant
qu'ils avaient un signe avant-coureur
nous aussi nous en sommes au courant
j'imagine que vous l'avez signalé et que
du coup on est allé contrôler cette
association spécifiquement ou les
associations dont vous faites état
puisque vous êtes au courant donc
évidemment qu'à chaque fois qu'on reçoit
des signalements
on va inspecter et c'est pas pour rien
qu'il y a les 170 contrôle ils sont pas
venus nous par ils sont venus ces deux
contrôles ciblés soit parce que le
ministère de l'intérieur suit
spécifiquement des personnes et qui nous
appellent pour venir avec eux dans les
associations sportives où ils pratiquent
ou parce qu'effectivement c'est des
signalements qui nous sont remontés par
les collectivités par les éducateurs eux
mêmes par les fédérations
et à ce moment là nous agissons donc oui
nous quand le problème existe nous le
traitons nous avons de quoi le traité
nous avons aujourd'hui un réseau mois là
où je veux simplement moduler le sujet
c'est que le pro le problème n'est pas
finalement celui que vous semblez
proposé celui de la neutralité ou pas du
sport vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
l'article 52 de la charte olympique
c'est bien cet article là qui va sans
doute nous permettre de voir à la
télévision des filles voilées faire du
sport pendant les jeux olympiques je
suis sûr que non bah oui mais dans cet
article 50 heures que non harry doit
être exemplaire
oui mais dans cet article rien quand il
avait mentionné que le port du voile est
un signe culturel et non pas cultuelle
oui donc ça n'irait pas du tout dans le
sens que vous voudriez sai si jamais on
inclut l article 50 dans les règlements
des fédérations dans le dans la charte
olympique
il n'ya pas là de voile et de la c est
un le voile est un symbole culturel
culturel pour le seuil haut non mais ça
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle par un
unissent des sports qui nous dit que non
je ne dis pas le scénario que le sort
dit que le voile est un symbole culturel
il ya des femmes qui se battent pour se
libérer qui doivent hurler à travers le
monde en entendant les propos pareils
aujourd'hui permettez-moi de le dire
parce que c'est quand même juste
hallucinant donc moi je suis là pour
leur apporter ça comme un vecteur
culturel le voile gérard moi je ne suis
pas pour que l'article 50 ou un article
de ce type sont inclus dans les
règlements de nos fédérations c'est vous
regrette donc
et pourquoi parce que justement il dit
que le voile c'est un bien ces objets
qu'ils sont le voile aujourd'hui que
l'article 50 soit dans les fédérations
ou pas pour vous ça pose pas de problème
d'eau pourquoi le mettre pour le coup
effectivement vous avez raison mais je
trouve quand même assez fou et madame la
présidente l'a dit que nous n'ayons pas
un constat objectif de ce qui se passe
dans les clubs sportifs alors évidemment
le ministère des sports n'a pas la main
sur les fédérations mais moi je suis élu
de banlieue
venez voir ce qui se passe dans les
banlieues
venez voir ce qui se passe sur les
terrains de foot le week-end les prières
les types qui refuse de serrer la main
des femmes c'est une réalité alors dans
des poches du territoire oui mais c'est
une réalité
on peut pas le nier moi je pense que ça
peut se discuter et ce travail et grâce
au sport ce n'est surtout si on en a
autorisé si le portique c'est normal
c'est un peu c'est parce que j'exigeais
pavie que le sport dit que c'est normal
jardin dit ça j'ai pas dit que le sport
dit que c'est normal j'ai dit que c'est
mc madhalim continuer à accepter tous
les publics comme ils sont comme il est
c'est tout les gars allez leur dire que
si vous dites ça vous ouvrez la porte à
tous vous ouvrez la porte à tout et
aujourd'hui si un condamné mais si un
combat et que le président lui-même
indiqué du séparatisme si on en met pas
des limites par tous n'est pas près de
s'en sortir et le sport doit y est tu
dois être un exemple
alors voilà donc je pense que c'est
important que une analyse de la réalité
nous en tout cas on la partage alors je
vais bien je pense que c'est compliqué
de gérer ces choses là mais plus on va
laisser faire plus ce sera compliqué a
ouai mais alors et moi je préfère que le
sport reconnaissent qu effectivement
c'est un sujet complexe n'est pas un
sujet simple qu'il se pose les questions
et les bonnes questions et surtout
qu'ils ne prennent pas le parti d'
exclure de fait mais au contraire de
pouvoir inclure reste et inclusif et
puis de faire barrage aux dérives et aux
dérives communautaires et aux notions de
séparatisme c'est ce que j'ai dit dans
mon propos introductif l'objet d'une
association sportive et surtout de
pratiquer un sport ensemble
de quelle que soit l'origine la religion
et la culture qui est la nôtre est de
veiller justement à ce que ces valeurs
républicaines de tolérance et de mixité
puisse puisse prévaloir dans un club
sportif il ya monsieur notre collègue le
fais je vais donner la parole à monsieur
antoine lefèvre notre collègue qui avec
vous dans la salle de 12h06 antoine si
madame la présidente eux mêmes le
rapporteur madame la ministre
moi je voudrais on est on évoquait les
signes vous avez justement dit que dans
la lutte contre la radicalisation vous
avez souhaité indiquer qu'ils fallait
signaler les signes de radicalisation
alors vous avez fait état d'un document
moi je voulais savoir si effectivement
il y avait eu pour les fédérations à
usage notamment des éducateurs se passe
de dvd mais comme en quelque sorte là
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure tu as
trouvé le pouvoir développer sur le
contenu là c'est plus j'ai l'impression
sur la notion de laïcité mais est ce que
en termes d'outils pratiques
puisqu'il faut signaler les signes
comment les détecter est ce que vous
avez à destination des fédérations et
des éducateurs en quelque sorte un guide
pratique de ce sur quoi il faut être
attentif et vigilant parce que la
plupart des vous l'avez dit vous-même il
ya dans les fédérations beaucoup de deux
personnes qui sont des bénévoles qui
n'ont pas forcément parle de culture qui
n'ont pas cette cette culture qui n'ont
pas la connaissance du fait religieux et
c'est aussi un des primes de notre pays
puisque les religions ne sont pas
enseignées en tant que tel donc les gens
forcément sur ces notions d une
connaissance souvent souvent diffuse
voire inexistantes
est-ce qu'il ya également aussi des
modules de formation à destination des
éducateurs est ce qu'il ya en tout cas
est ce que c'est en projet est ce qu
elles sont en quelque sorte
l'ensemble des du panel d'outils que
votre ministère est en capacité de
donner encore une fois le sujet est
complexe mais ils on a besoin de doughty
et notamment toutes ces fédérations et
tous ses bénévoles au bénéfice des
éducateurs donc j'aurais voulu avoir les
outils concrets et peut-être revenir sur
le document si c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement est diffusée largement
vous évoquez aussi les conférences
régionales que vous allez organiser
voilà c'est un peu sur l'ensemble de la
notion d' outil pratique parce qu'il
faut être pratiquée c'est pour là dessus
que je voulais vous interrogez pour
diffuser tous ces outils je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure qui existait donc le
guide de la laïcité prévenir la
radicalisation dans le champ du sport
qui donne le mode d'emploi de comment
repérer lorsque les hommes ne serre pas
la main aux femmes
lorsque ils vont dans les vestiaires
pour utiliser le vestiaire pour faire la
prière lorsque dans des repas
il impose est imposée à tout le monde
une sorte de nourriture il y a la
possibilité
effectivement d'identifier ces signes de
les reporter d'alerté et puis derrière
de déclencher les contrôles dont je vous
ai parlé
nous avons besoin des collectivités pour
distribuer ses affiches aide pour
pouvoir les mettre dans les équipements
et c'est pour ça que l'utilité de l'
agence nationale du sport va être
vraiment présent dans les prochaines
années parce que c'est un outil de
discussions avec les territoires où
effectivement il ya là la possibilité de
j'allais dire de sortir uniquement de la
relation état fédération que nous avons
bien investi que nous allons encore plus
investir à partir de cette année avec un
contrat de délégation renforçait qui
vont qui va mentionner toutes les
données d'éthique et d'intégrité que
nous voulons faire respecter aux
fédérations délégataires et qui inclura
le le respect de ses valeurs citoyennes
mais pour le monde associatif
ni la fédération ni l'état ne peut avoir
la main sur tout le tissu associatif 380
mille associations en france
nous allons avoir besoin des mairies des
territoires des directeurs des sports
qui vont prendre la mesure aussi au
moment d'attribuer les subventions
directement aux associations qui lie à
la nécessité d'avoir une espèce de
contrats d' usage de ces équipements
moyennant le respect de dunes d'une
convention républicaine d'une charte
républicaine à définir voilà par par
chaque élu de chaque mairie où il y à
des associations sportives donc nous
allons intervenir et nous intervenons
actuellement par le biais fédéral nous
intervenons par le biais de nos services
déconcentrés pour contrôler mais aussi
formés et sensibilisés
aider à repérer a détecté pour pouvoir
venir derrière contrôler mais
effectivement pour couvrir tout le
maillage territorial associatif
nous avons édité des outils que nous
allons diffuser via l' agence nationale
des sports avec une session spécifique
au moment de chaque conférence
territoriale de lagence avoir à côté de
chaque conférence régionale une un temps
éthique et intégrité ou seront abordées
toutes ces thématiques radicalisation
dopage et violences sexuelles dans le
sport de manière à voir comment
mobiliser les collectivités pour qu'elle
se saisisse des outils produits par le
ministère en remercie est ce que il ya
d'autres collègues j'ai une bonne gifle
de ces questions parce qu'une seule une
seule une seule s'il te plaît parce que
tout à l'heure vous voulez être parvenu
sur le quelque chose que vous avez
développé début de vos propres mains des
ministres sur la mixité des pratiques
c'est que ça veut dire quoi concrètement
la mixité des pratiques dans vos
objectifs la mixité des pratiques c'est
pouvoir pratiquer au sein d'une
association avec les filles et les
garçons ensemble avec les personnes
handicapées incluse aussi dans cette
pratique et avec des différentes
sections si le sport le nécessitent
parce que c'est parfois un sport
d'équipé qui se joue entre vers son
autre fille et quand ce n'est pas un
sport d'équipé valoriser le fait qu'il
doit y avoir une mixité des publics
qu'il soit accueilli et dans chaque
association pour des raisons j'allais
dire éthiques et républicaines mais
aussi pour des raisons économiques
nous poussons les associations à ce
qu'elle s'adresse à tous les types de
publics et pas simplement un public
qu'elle touche est historiquement pour
pas parler des filles et des garçons qui
touchent parfois qui peut toucher à des
convictions religieuses
je le prendrais l'exemple plutôt de la
pyramide des âges où historiquement les
clubs sportifs s'adresse plutôt à des
jeunes enfants et des adolescents et non
pas tellement d'offres a proposé pour
les personnes adultes ou les personnes
de troisième âge et on n'en comprend pas
forcément la raison donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on veut développer
c'est effectivement la mixité des
pratiques au sein de chaque association
et que chaque association couvre
l'intégralité des publics et évidemment
nous avons un implant nous spécifique de
développement de la pratique féminine au
ministère des sports où on veut prendre
plus en compte la spécificité féminine
dans la pratique et le fait aussi que
ces femmes puissent arriver de manière
comme je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
plus facile aux instances dirigeantes
pour pouvoir voilà accéder à des postes
est forcément donné derrière aussi une
dimension plus plus féminine et plus
familial à l'offre qui sera proposé par
l'association la fédération en question
je rappelle simplement que sur prendre
quatre fédérations olympiques nous avons
aujourd'hui
depuis peu une deuxième femme présidente
de fédération et que tous les présidents
de fédérations sont des hommes sur
toutes nos fédérations olympiques
ce n'est pas le cas sur les fédérations
affinitaires mais voilà c'était une
véritable problématique aujourd'hui
sachant que la dernière loi a proposé
une parité mais pas
égal mais progressive sur les instances
dans les dans les conseils
d'administration et au niveau national
mais pas du tout dans les services
déconcentrés enfin dans les structures
déconcentrées des fédérations et encore
moins voilà dans les associations ont
finalement on ne peut pas l'imposer on
ne peut que l'encourager et on ne peut
que l'encourager en favorisant une offre
adaptée aux femmes est effectivement là
encore on va être sur un champ où je
suis sûr qu'on en débatte en vous et moi
vous et moi vous allez me dire oui mais
il faut surtout pas proposer des
créneaux spécifiques aux femmes parce
que sinon l'interprétation on va s aide
et en même temps il y à des temps de la
vie des femmes où on va avoir besoin de
sport je pense notamment à la maternité
où effectivement après un accouchement
c'est plutôt les femmes qu'on va
accueillir de manière privilégiée par
les hommes même si effectivement on peut
leur trouver une place spécifique dans
un entraînement quelconque mais voilà le
le fait aussi de ce que je veux dire
c'est que derrière tout ça il ya aussi
une interprétation
voilà le sujet de la commission denquête
c'est pas 2 c'est pas les femmes dans le
sport c'est la radicalisation dans le
sport donc cueillait des créneaux pour
des femmes pour de la gym poste
maternité c'est pas le sujet je pense
que ça c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
savoir jusqu'où on peut combattre la
radicale sion dans la société et via et
dans le sport parce qu'il existe ça
existe aussi
est ce que vous vous avez vous avez
ciblé des sports plus spécifiquement
touchés par ces problèmes de
radicalisation est-ce que vous avez
probablement des sports qui sont avant
tout pas touché par ça et d'autre est ce
que vous allez ciblées alors dans les
greens rôle dans les contrôles ciblés
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure les
les 171 ils ont été faits principalement
dans les sports de combat dans les
sports collectifs comme
et particulièrement dans les disciplines
où on a détecté
voilà parmi les 1000 personnes du coup
conquis qui font partie du fichier du
ministère de l'intérieur on a détecté
qu'ils étaient plutôt dans tel sport que
d'autres sports et les sports de tir les
sports effectivement de combat et les
sports collectifs où on peut penser
qu'effectivement il y a matière à voir
ce phénomène de groupe et d'incitation
de prosélytisme actif effectivement qui
serait sujet à une possible
radicalisation est aussi l'utilité de
ces sports dans l'action terroriste elle
qu'on pourrait l'envisager parce qu on y
apprend à se battre on apprend à
l'utilisation des armes à feu donc
évidemment nous portons une attention
particulière sur ces sports mais encore
une fois cette attention particulière
est posée par le ministère de
l'intérieur
et lorsque nous venons avec eux c'est en
soutien et en traducteur de ce qui se
passe dans l'écosystème sportif pour
pouvoir leur dire bon ça c'est ça peut
vous paraître anormal mais finalement
dans un contexte sportif c'est normal ou
là il ya vraiment un problème est
effectivement par rapport à l'habitude
qu'on a de contrôle des associations
sportives ca c c'est un comportement
anormal
alors j'aurai une question d'âme la
ministre vous avez effectivement dit
vous auriez besoin et collectivités
locales je pense qu'elles ont aussi
besoin de vous est ce que vous envisagez
d'aller expliquer à ces collectivités
locales en faisant un tour de france
leur remettre les outils de rencontrer
les maires puisque vous dites que
visiblement nous avons des informations
vous ne vais pas les noms nous avons
auditionné des associations d'élus
conditionner des personnes qui
interviennent auprès d'organismes de
formation qui a terminé auprès de l'élu
et qui effectivement nous ont fait
signalement est ce que vous envisagez
d'aller à la rencontre de ces élus de
leur expliquer effectivement ce que vous
mettez en place et d'avoir une
discussion avec eux parce que je pense
que c'est toujours plus facile aussi de
le faire hein
en direct est ce que c'est
au programme de vos prochains
déplacements dans les différentes dans
les différents départements
alors personnellement je l' ai déjà fait
c'est à villeneuve la garenne l'année
dernière on nous avons et fait
effectivement ce type de réunion avec
avec les élus avec les associations
locales nos services déconcentrés pour
que nos services déconcentrés puisse me
montrer en fait grandeur nature ce à
quoi ressemblait ces sessions de
sensibilisation de formation en local
c'est effectivement ce que nos services
déconcentrés au ministère des sports oms
comme une comme actions locales à savoir
ils vont dans plusieurs villes
réunissent les élus aux sports les
directeurs des sports les les encadrants
associatif et il leur explique pendant
une demi journée une journée entière ce
qu'est le fait religieux dans dans le
sport comment leur père et comment le
signaler et quelle est la part des
choses et la définition des termes est
effectivement qu'elle est aussi la loi
par rapport à cela puisque encore une
fois je reprends cet parce que ça s'est
passé là bas lorsque l'association
sportive m'a dit ah bah oui j'ai vu
cette fille avec le voile je lui ai dit
d'entrer chez elle
clairement ce que ce que ce qui a été
rétorqué derrière par mes services et
oui mais si cette jeune fille avait
porté plainte aujourd'hui dans le droit
français tel qu'il est aujourd'hui elle
aurait eu raison elle aurait eu gain de
cause et vous aurez du lard est acceptée
effectivement la laïcité aujourd'hui
dans ce dans ce ce temps de respiration
laïque qui est le sport par rapport à la
vie des des enfants qui vont à l'école
de 8 heures à 17 heures le soir c'est
effectivement pas entendable du fait de
la loire aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est
écrite maintenant c'est vous les
législateurs le législateur s'il faut
changer la loi
voilà moi c'est pas je je j'aimerais
qu'on reste justement sur un sport
telles que je viens de vous le décrire
ensuite
est-ce qu'on envisage de le faire un
niveau plus large
oui avec les conférences régionales de
la jeunesse de l' agence nationale des
sports lorsque la déclinaison
territoriale sera installé sur tous les
territoires on compte redémarrer le
travail aujourd'hui puisque le décret
sont aujourd'hui en commun ils ont été
validés secondaire les décrets pour l'
agence pour la déclinaison pour
septembre on va démarrer la déclinaison
territoriale effective de l'agencé et ce
sera le moment
danser à un niveau régional certes ce
sera pas un niveau municipal
mais ce sera le moment où on pourra
apporter ses messages on pourra
effectivement montré et expliqué les
outils que nous produisons et et laisser
les acteurs s'en emparer et voir comment
ils peuvent les décliner voilà vous
venez de suivre l'audition de la
ministre des sports elle était invitée à
s'exprimer sur le thème de la
radicalisation islamiste dans le sport
amateur et professionnel la
radicalisation à thème suivi avec grand
intérêt par le sénat puisqu'il s'agit de
la troisième commission d' enquête sur
le sujet depuis 2015
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi
restez avec nous l'information continue
sur public sénat
[Musique]